hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
one of several key themes that are woven
together in Audrey Lord's address the
uses of anger is that of racism and
anger as a legitimate response to racism
and indeed we can broaden it as she does
in the work to discrimination more
generally she's going to talk not only
about racism but also about sexism and
discrimination against other groups
including the poor at one point and we
should begin with looking at how she
characterizes racism she's not
attempting to provide some sort of
blanket definition that covers every
single case but to at least identify it
in a way that can be useful for what she
is is doing in this piece the kind of
analysis she's engaged in so she Begins
by saying racism the belief in in the
inherent superiority of One race over
all others and thereby the right to
dominance manifest and implied so let's
look at the first part somebody might
quibble and say well then you can't be a
racist if there's like a hierarchy and
you're not at the very top of it well no
as a matter of fact you could be a
racist and just not see your race as the
one that needs to be privileged above
all others but so long as there's some
sort of hierarchy of races there is
going to be racism particularly when the
hierarchy has to do with all sorts of
characteristics that are being imputed
to people of various groups that we call
races and you know here we could also go
into a long discussion about is race
something real sociologically it's
certainly is and in the Amer America
that she is writing in and I would say
in the America of today this is
something that we see quite often
reflected in a number of different
experiences structural inequalities and
we could go on and on and on what we
really want to think about are the key
dimensions of what it is that she is
saying she has anger over so belief in
the inherent superiority of One race
over another that's something cognitive
that's something that people think and
then you know along with that a right to
dominance to dominance doesn't
necessarily mean bossing people around
it could also be hoarding resources or
enjoying opportunities as if it's you
know an unquestioned privilege that
other people don't enjoy like you know
getting interviews for jobs and it could
be manifest meaning that it's you know
out there and we see it or just in
implied it's something implicit part of
the way things are held to work and then
she talks about three really important
dimensions of this
attitudes ways in which people display
this belief right how they act upon it
how they treat other people outright
actions you know she mentions for
example one Extreme Action a lynching of
a pregnant woman but there could be all
sorts of other actions as well or
failures to act for example holding a
conference on racism and then not
providing resources for those who can't
afford to go to the conference to
actually get there and waving their
conference fees so that they can present
or participate and then presumptions
presumptions is also something you could
say that is cognitive
assumptions about things judgments that
we make and that uh might be you know
above board might be quite open or might
be just implicit and so this isn't the
totality of racism but it's a good
starting point and Lord is going to be
writing to her fellow women and
specifically feminists it's sort of like
Martin Luther King's letter from a
Birmingham Jail which is an open letter
but is addressed specifically to those
who he you know would like to be making
common cause with his fellow clergyman
she is writing to her fellow women who
are supposed to be feminists organized
against another kind of ism sexism
treating women differently than men or
if we want to expand it to include you
know the entire lgbtq Spectrum right
that could be part of it there's also
she brings up issues of poverty which
can be something there and one of the
key things that she's trying to say here
is yet racism exists racism is a
significant part of our society it's not
going to be rooted out right away it
should provoke anger on the part of
those who suffer from it or even those
who witness it and are of good faith
right and recognize it
feminists are organized against sexism
and against misogyny but they can also
within their overarching Community
exhibit forms of racism and you know we
could also talk about classism or other
things as well just being against one
kind of discrimination or Injustice does
not automatically make you
attune to others and she's saying that
this is a significant problem within the
feminist community and she gives a lot
of examples I'll just bring up one of
these the women's studies program of a
Southern University invites a black
woman to read following a week-long
forum on black and white women what has
this week given you I ask the most vocal
white woman says I think I've gotten a
lot I feel black women really understand
me a lot better now they have a better
idea of where I'm coming from as if
understanding her lay at the core of the
racist problem Audrey Lord observes and
you know I think you can see the the
sort of entitlement there so you know
she thinks that there can be
um racism directed by white women
against black women and she calls that
out in a number of ways and this can
even be exhibited in the responses to
the anger that somebody like audre Lorde
will let out and act upon and Advocate
that anger makes white women feel
fearful or guilty or angry themselves or
as if you know this shouldn't be part of
what's going on and Lord to her credit a
little bit after that
says that um
this isn't just you know a black white
thing and uh you know who's who's least
powerful or something like that
everybody has to take responsibility for
themselves and she talks about uh the
possibility of ignoring other women of
color she says when I speak of women of
color I do not only mean black women the
woman of color who is not black and who
charges me with rendering her Invisible
by assuming that her struggles with
racism are identical with my own has
something to tell me that I had better
learn from unless we both waste
ourselves fighting the truths between us
if I participate knowingly or otherwise
in my sister's oppression and she calls
me on it to answer her anger with my own
only blankets the substance of our
exchange with reaction it wastes energy
and yes it is very difficult to stand
still and listen to another woman's
voice delineate an agony I do not share
or one to which I myself have
contributed and so you know Lord is
saying it's it's this isn't something
easy for people to deal with to
to hear others saying hey you have hurt
me you have humiliated me you are doing
things against me when you don't realize
that you're you're doing that can be
very difficult and so
um you know if there was a suddenly a
new class of people we'll call them
greens you know maybe modeled after the
hulks that would be an issue as well so
merely organizing against one kind of
discrimination doesn't automatically
mean that across the board you're an
ally or you know helping out or in
solidarity you could in fact be
perpetuating the problem she also talks
about what we can identify she doesn't
use this word but we can identify as
sort of a dynamic of displacement she
says I've seen situations where white
women hear a racist remark resent what
has been said become filled with Fury
but remain silent because they're afraid
that unexpressed anger lies within them
like an undetonated device usually to be
hurled at the first woman of color who
talks about racism so people who are not
within you could call it the privileged
class that gets to do what they want and
have to suffer in dignities when they
see uh you know major injustices being
talked about they kind of stuff it down
because they themselves are afraid and
then when they're dealing with somebody
else who is more vulnerable and probably
closer to the heart of the you know
racist Dynamic then they let that anger
go on the wrong target not directed
against those who perpetuate or act upon
or Advocate racism but rather against
those who are rightly criticizing it so
Lord thinks that anger is in fact
a proper response to racism at the very
beginning
after delineating what she means by
racism she says women respond to racism
so there's a variety of possible
responses my response she goes on is
anger
I have lived with that anger ignoring it
feeding upon it learning to use it
before I laid my Visions to waste for
most of my life once I did it in silence
afraid of the weight my fear of anger
taught me nothing and then she says I'm
you know eventually able to express my
anger and she says my anger is a
response to racist attitudes and to the
actions and presumptions that arise out
of those attitudes if you're dealing
with other women reflect those attitudes
then my anger and your attended fears
are spotlights that can be used for
growth this goes to the uses of anger
that she's using in the title right so
Lord views uh anger as a legitimate
response
to racism and we might pause here for a
moment and think about that well why
would that be a legitimate response is
anger a legitimate response to other
injustices I think many of us would say
that it is unless we've been told that
anger is automatically bad or wrong and
you notice that you know who does she
talk about as those who are not supposed
to express anger women and other people
in vulnerable positions Lord is saying
no anger is actually an appropriate
response to racist attitudes and she'll
um go on and add to this
she tells us that it's a appropriate
reaction not just a response but a
reaction and then she goes a little bit
further and she says that it also is
appropriate to feel Fury and she's using
a term that's often synonymous with
anger but in it talks about an
intensified kind of anger Fury at racist
actions that are not changing
so we've got two different things here
uh legitimate response to racist
attitudes
and fury at actions why because actions
are something that are more tangible
that Change the World perhaps more than
racist attitudes
and she tells us that oftentimes
expressions of rage are dismissed as
being
as she puts it the two most common
accusations are that the anger or the
rage is useless and disruptive now why
would people say that because they can't
handle they can't deal with they can't
use the expression of people who are
legitimately angered by racism
just being expressed maybe they they
feel fear and guilt as a result right
that's very often what happens or they
feel anger themselves or it triggers
something else within them
and she also says that women have to
learn how to deal with other women's
anger constructively and she she says
here most women have not developed tools
for facing anger constructively
Consciousness raising groups in the past
largely white dealt with how to express
anger usually at the world of men so
feminists you know she has in mind are
targeting and calling out sexism
but they're not learning how to deal
with the anger that arises not you know
from somebody else oppressing them as a
group but within their own group over
different lines like racism or poverty
or other Associated things we might
think of disability as an example as
well and so she goes on and she says
these groups were made up of white women
who shared the terms of their
oppressions there was usually little
attempt to articulate the genuine
differences between women what would
these genuine differences between women
include race color age class sexual
identity there was no apparent need at
that time to examine the contradictions
of self women as oppressor there was
work on expressing anger but very little
on anger directed against each other no
tools were developed to deal with other
women's anger anger except to avoid it
deflect it flee from it under a blanket
of guilt and so you know these
accusations of useless and disruptive
come about
within that situation and Lord is saying
that anger needs to actually be
expressed it doesn't mean that everybody
has to start blowing everything up or
tearing everything down or raging
against every single thing it actually
has to be focused as she says with
precision
but it should be
out there within a space that is created
for it because it is legitimate
another thing she talks about is that
very often people who are in uh you know
sort of marginalized or exploited
positions are expected to do more she
says oppressed peoples are always being
asked to stretch a little more to bridge
the gap between blindness and Humanity
black women are expected to use our
anger only in the service of other
people's salvation or learning not for
themselves they're not being treated as
full agents as equal to other people
when it comes to anger and she says that
time is over my anger has meant pain to
me but it's also meant survival and here
we get to perhaps one of the other
really high points of what she's saying
and Lord could be misunderstood as being
sort of an apologist for anger at any
time at any place and it's very clear
that that's not the case
she also doesn't see anger as something
that is inherently good by itself
because one of the things that she's
saying close to the ending of this is
before I give it up my anger I'm going
to be sure that there's something at
least as powerful to replace it on the
road to Clarity so she's holding out the
possibility that you know anger despite
having its uses maybe it needs to be
replaced by something else but there
needs to be something else truly worked
out and available before people should
be expected to abandon their legitimate
anger over things like racism or other
types of Oppression Injustice and
discrimination that we find in you know
individual relationships in the
workplace and you know Medical Care in
universities and organizations in
government in all sorts of other aspects
of our culture and Society so Lord's
key Point here that we've been
developing is that anger is in fact a
legitimate response to the injustices
that are involved in racism or other
forms of discrimination